what i want to do in this video is think
about what type of reaction we might
have if we have ingredients very similar
to what we saw in the last video but
instead of our nucleophile or our base
being meth methoxide it's going to be
something slightly more involved so it's
still going to have the o minus but it's
going to be bonded to a carbon which is
then bonded to three methyl groups ch3
ch3
ch3 just like that so we don't have
methoxide anymore
we don't have methoxide anymore we have
this thing right over here so just like
before we have the exact same solvent we
have dimethyl formamide it's an aprotic
solvent that by itself would push it put
us in the sn2 or e2 direction but now we
don't have methoxide anymore methoxide
was both a strong base very strong base
and it's also a very small molecule and
so it can really get in there and react
with the substrate so it's also a strong
nucleophile now this more
bulky molecule it is still a strong base
it is still
an extremely strong base but now it's
this big bulky molecule would actually
have trouble getting in to react with
your substrate so it is no longer a good
nucleophile this is not a good
nucleophile so by making the base more i
guess bulky it's now and or i guess you
could also call it the nucleophile or
the thing that would act as a
nucleophile more bulky it is no longer a
strong nucleophile so it would no longer
be good for an sn2 reaction so just by
changing the base a little bit or the
nucleophile a little bit now this one
would go strictly in the e2 direction e2
direction so we wouldn't see anything we
wouldn't see anything like this in the
last video we would only see something
like this but and obviously the the base
in this in this example is no longer
just a methoxide it looks like this
it looks like this let me clear it
do my best to clear it
edit clear let me clear it over here as
well
let me clear it over here as well so now
instead of just being bonded to a methyl
group it's bonded to a carbon
it's bonded to a carbon that's bonded to
three methyl groups so c
h3
ch3 ch3 or you could call this a
tert-butyl group this whole thing over
here so that's a carbon bonded to a ch3
a ch3 and a ch3 so the reaction occurs
just like what we saw in the last video
except this base is this big old bulky
thing but it can still act as a strong
base it still nabs the hydrogen or
really just the proton the hydrogen's
electron that was bonded now goes to the
alpha carbon the alpha carbon will then
use lose an electron to the bromo group
and that becomes bromide so the same
exact mechanism different base but that
base is now not a good nucleophile so
you won't see sn2 occurring at all you
will only see e2